adam is in valdosta georgia hi
adam how are you hey dave hey chris
thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help i'm in a position
where
um with my career i'm trying to go back
to school and get a degree
to further my career and i'm in a
position where
it's possible that i may have to go into
debt
to get this degree
with my career classes can be
transferred over into credit into this
specific
university online university and
there's no way i this is the only one
that
moves all the classes i've ever taken
into
college credits so i'm trying to
struggle because i'm i'm doing my debt
snowball
i'm struggling with handling the debt
that i have
and trying to stay debt-free for my
degree
and what's your degree what's your
degree field i'm trying to get a
bachelor's or four-year degree in
business administration
okay and how much do you lack
um i have depending on how many
credit hours my classes for my career
move over
i have only my core classes so i'm
fairly fresh into it
so you got like three years of work left
yeah i mean
right and i could cut i could cut that
in half
almost if i go to this university
because it'll transfer all my career
stuff over
so you'd have a year and some change
left you'd be in your senior year or
late in your junior year correct okay
all right and what do you do for a
living i'm a firefighter
okay how old are you i am 26.
okay and so the business degree does
what for you
it allows me for it's one of our
requirements for promotion in the future
as a firefighter you need a business
degree uh
as a higher level an administration
level
uh chief oh actually okay yeah
it's a further down on my career path
yeah
all right and how many years before you
would be eligible for
that um position if you had this degree
if i had a degree i would say
roughly five to ten years
it's rough to say but at least five yeah
okay and um how many colleges are in
valdosta
um three i believe
okay yep three yeah and you're
the one you're looking at though is
online correct
not one of those three no uh this is the
only
this university or the online university
is the only one that
moves all my i got that part i got that
part
have you talked to all three of the
others i have
okay because they are much cheaper than
the online
yes a fourth aren't they
um roughly yeah yeah so that's what
you're doing you're either gonna
go over there and talk one of them into
this
and uh appeal i mean sit down in the
president's office just stroll your butt
in there
and sit down and go i'm getting ready to
move everything to an online and pay too
much
for this degree because you guys won't
transfer these credits so we've got to
figure out something because this is
crazy i would rather
keep the money here in our community i'm
a firefighter here in this community
i'd rather keep the money here in the
community and support our local college
and
it's better for me to say i graduated
from this local community and it is by
the way
right yeah you're not going to go into
debt and go online
matter of fact i think the online idea
is just a bad idea because i think
you're paying way too much for the
stinking degree
that you don't need for seven years
right so i would just nix that and i i
think you just got to do some
politicking on the transfer
because the thing these are small
colleges this isn't like you're trying
to go
the freaking harvard and get them to
waive your you know accept your credits
right this is valdosta state or whatever
it is for god's sakes
i mean it's not like it's it's not a i'm
not putting it down i'm you'll probably
get a great education there
but my point is you'll have access to
people probably that have an open mind
oh by the way they
they actually want students need
students they definitely
i'm going to go in there and find out
what the appeals process is or
who i have to appeal to or who who needs
to stroke a
agreement an executive order waiving
this i don't know how it works even yeah
i wish dr
john was here because he would know it
because it baffles me because even with
a community college they will take their
credits not give you the grades some
some of them but i mean i'm going to
communicate adam take the opportunity or
the thought of going into debt off the
table
exactly that's what i want you to do
just because right now you've got that
looking like it's the only option to you
and it's really not i'd much rather you
go have that conversation go low and
slow
as you're going part time and it takes
you longer to get the degree with
avoiding debt we got 43 million people
walking around
with 1.7 trillion in student loan debt
you
you don't want to go there yeah and all
and a percentage of them
whining at the top of their lungs
expecting the government to forgive
their debt now
um we've got the um the lefties you know
going bananas on this stuff now
and so oh we should all have it forgiven
we should know and so you know i'm going
to be telling you
no no no no no no now the other question
that i would
bring into play here
i understand that you need the knowledge
pieces
to be an administrator in a leadership
position that high that
the business leadership but um
i might even challenge that the degree
is a hundred percent a prerequisite for
you moving up into those roles
i think if you could exhibit and show
the knowledge that was in place
right you probably might be eligible for
that
as well i i actually have never run into
that before but that doesn't mean
that you're not correct i'm just saying
i haven't run into it and so it does
make sense it's logical sense that to be
in an administrative role as senior
chief of the chief of
uh fire chief for the whole county or
whatever that kind of a thing that you
would need some
uh organizational administrative
uh skill sets that you would get in a
four-year business degree
right that's logical to me i'd even have
the conversation with the chief there to
find out can i enroll in the national
guard
well or will they pay for it yeah i mean
i want to have the conversation on this
to find out and understand it more
uh but adam thanks for reaching out
buddy it's very cool you can hear it's
heavy on your heart you need some more
options and to have some conversations
and keep gathering information the the
trick is as chris said take the debt off
the table it's not an option
and then from there what are we going to
do we've got to find another way to get
this
goal accomplished and that's what i keep
poking out around the edges here what
are the options to still accomplish the
goal
with no debt yeah and and you know
either cash flowing it
national guard fire department chips in
i don't care doesn't matter to me i hate
that you would pay four times more
because you can't get the local college
to accept the transfer credits
which is illogical by the way on top of
that so it means you've got a good case
as far as i'm concerned